dites à kiev le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a une nouvelle fois affiché
son soutien au président ukrainien face
à la menace russe
depuis des semaines près de cent mille
soldats russes sont massés à la
frontière est de l'ukraine laissant
craindre une invasion anthony blinken a
appelé vladimir poutine à choisir la
paix
dans ce contexte explosif les etats unis
ont annoncé mercredi le déblocage de 200
millions de dollars dettes sécuritaire à
l'ukraine en plus des 450 millions déjà
fourni moscou nie toute volonté
d'envahir son voisin mais refuse toute
désescalade avant d'avoir la garantie
que l'ukraine ne rejoindra jamais l'otan
bonus
[Musique]
mystique
mathieu
bodmer
anthony blinken se rendra jeudi à berlin
pour des discussions avec ses alliés
européens avant un tête à tête avec son
homologue russe à genève vendredi une
énième tentative pour trouver une porte
de sortie diplomatique à la crise